joe biden's credibility is shredded he
said he's going to stop the virus he has
not he said that he wasn't going to kill
the economy he has he's destroyed our
credibility on the international stage
and this is an unsuccessful failed
presidency and we are not even a year in
that house plans is beginning to wilt in
serious fashion
so in breaking news by the way the
august jobs report is out complete fail
complete absolute utter failure which of
course is not surprising because we are
paying people to stay home and then
we're talking about inflating more we're
talking about more stimulus we're
talking about by the way telling people
that they must stay home because of the
pandemic when that is obviously not true
if you're vaccinated you should not be
afraid of other people who are
unvaccinated because you're vaccinated
it's the whole damned point of getting
vaccinated in the first place
so
the reality there's a reason why these
states that are doing best in terms of
the
unemployment rate are all red states and
the states that are all doing the worst
are the blue states there's a reason for
that the august jobs report how bad was
it
economists had forecasted 725 000 jobs
being created remember there are 10
million open jobs in the united states
right now
725 000 jobs is what the economists have
been forecasting the actual number of
jobs created
was 235 000 jobs they were off by a
factor of three they're off by a factor
of three
that is a disaster area for the biden
administration and again they keep
missing the mark they keep missing it
over and over they'll have like one good
month and then they'll have three
terrible months
that is because you have completely
destroyed all of the incentive
structures causing people to go back to
work you've destroyed supply lines
you're artificially boosting demand by
pouring money into people's pockets but
you can tell by the way that that sort
of inflation is not actual price
inflation it's not sort of heated it's
not economic heating you know how you
know because if you look at the loan
numbers like whether people are actually
taking out loans the answer is no people
are not taking out loans under these
circumstances because they're afraid
they're not going to be able to pay them
back
and that is because the underlying
fundamentals that are being created by
the regulate and spend and tax biden
economy are a lot weaker than the
fundamentals of an economy that was much
more laissez faire under donald trump
this is this is wild i mean so
the fed is now saying that the august
jobs of course was was a failure
but because of that they're going to
keep buying assets did ever occur to
them that the reason the jobs reports a
failure is because you keep inflating
the currency is because you keep paying
people to stay home it's because of
unemployment benefits it's because
you're creating
enormous pressure for businesses to
spend more money than they are actually
taking in on employees
like this is all causing inflation of
course and um but they're saying it's
transitory which is fine
terrible news for the economy not a
shock the unemployment rate fell to 5.2
in august from 5.4
before according to the bureau of labor
statistics
there's a reason why bitcoin by the way
just rose past 50 000 per bitcoin
the reason for that is because people
are now investing in some form of more
solid asset than the united states
dollar given what the federal government
is doing right now
by the way
uh according to the the economic report
there were job losses in certain sectors
in the retail sector almost 30 000 jobs
lost in the restaurant sector 42 000
jobs lost
and there were 36 000 jobs picked up in
the entertainment sector that's probably
gonna take a nosedive considering that
joe biden continues to shut down the
economy that's amazing what the people
in in the media they're going to
attribute this to the delta spike
the reality is that the only reason that
you are seeing shutdowns right now and
tremendous fear right now is because the
media have made it seem as though even
if you are vaccinated you should be
afraid this goes back to a point i was
making yesterday about covet which
really is the salient point if you had
to draw a chart of the worried and the
unworried when it comes to
when it comes to covet i'm actually
gonna do it for you right now okay here
we have a circle it's the worried here
we have a circle it is the unworried
okay
these are the two circles of the
american population
okay the unworried contain some people
who are vaccine who are vaccinated right
i'm unworried and i'm vaccinated so some
part of this circle
are the vaccinated okay but the rest of
this circle are the unvaxed the entirety
of the people who are unvaxed are
unworried i say that because if they
were worried they would go get faxed it
is the best solution to your worry is to
get faxed okay but then if you look at
the circle of the word
there the entire circle
the entire circle is vaccinated of the
worried okay the entirety of the circle
is vaccinated
so right now you have the biden
administration basically
telling the vaccinated to shut down the
economy worry about the vaccinated worry
worry worry worried okay but those are
the people who shouldn't be worried
we're now at the point where if you are
a sentient adult in the united states
and you don't have some unbelievably
severe pre-existing condition in which
your doctor says you shouldn't get a
vaccine
you have the option to do whatever the
hell you want
if the economy is shutting down it's
because of joe biden joe biden's
credibility is shredded he said he's
gonna stop the virus he has not he said
that he wasn't gonna kill the economy he
has he said that he was going to shore
up our credibility onto on the
international stage not only is he not
on that he's destroyed our credibility
on the international stage
and now all the big hopes that he had
for restructuring the nature of american
government they ride
on joe manchin and kirsten cinema
and this is an unsuccessful failed
presidency and we are not even a year in
that houseplant is beginning to wilt in
serious fashion
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang